It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa!
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
And today we're your hosts of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Ruffians, thank you for waking up and joining us today for our 135th episode!
BAU BAU!
Are you sure?
It's 135th episode?
Only 135 episodes.
What do you mean only 135 episodes?
Only 135!
Do you think you should be 175 today, Moco-chan?
In fact, yes.
1C5?
1C5!
Yes!
You've only woken up 130- I'm pretty sure there's been more times you've woken up than 135 times.
That's 100 times that you woke up.
And FUWAMOCO Morning was there to greet you!
BAU BAU!
Well, hello fans who are joining us for the very first time today!
FUWAMOCO Morning is a short format morning show held every Friday, Wednesday, and Monday!
A.K.A.
FUWAMOCO!
And it's hosted by us!
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw.
Please tweet your thoughts with the hashtag #FWMCMORNING!
Let's all BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
A new morning in a week?
And all of a sudden October has just about ended too.
That's really frightening.
That means it's almost November, Ruffians, and that's pretty much winter.
I'm not okay with that.
Are we ready for this?
I'm not ready for it.
Are we ready for that yet?
Do we agree to this?
Don't say that.
I'm sorry, it's Halloween.
It's almost Halloween.
At least there's a little Halloween.
That's exciting, right, Moco-chan?
Scary games.
Exciting.
Now.
Well, the scary things are for later into the month, right Moco-chan?
But now, we have disappointing stuff!
Can I have scary stuff instead of disappointing stuff?
Disappointing first.
Let's take a look then.
Well.
You know how it goes!
I know how it goes!
Ruffians spotted Pero.
Ruffians sent us Pero, which is good because then we can be informed when he was seen.
But it's still disappointing.
It's still disappointing.
You're Oshicording!
No!
Disappointment!
It's disappointment for you!
That's disappointing for me to hear that your oshi is Pero.
Let's see, where was he spotted?
Let's take a look.
De-den!
Wait, wait.
A petal pumpkin.
Petal pumpkin.
A bit of a petal pumpkin.
A little bit of a petal pumpkin.
Petal pumpkin.
A petal petal pumpkin.
Petal petal pumpkin.
Don't petal petal the petal pumpkin.
I don't know who I'm with.
He's nasty usually, right?
But as a pumpkin like this, he can't talk badly.
Yeah, he can't fly.
No, he can't do anything really.
I guess the only thing he can do is just bring some Halloween spookiness to us.
Right.
And disappointment.
This is the best outcome though, right, Ruffians?
Yes!
Yeah, Pup Pero!
Pup Pero!
Pero Pero Pumpkin!
Pumpkin pie!
I present a Pero Pero Pumpkin!
I don't know!
Take it on this form now!
Yeah, and you know, once Halloween passes, he's just gonna rot away and become one with the soil.
Right!
This is the best!
Yeah, I don't know if we can make him into a pumpkin.
I think that'd be a pretty nasty pumpkin pie.
He's already a pumpkin.
We can't make him into a pumpkin when he's already a pumpkin.
Yeah.
But yeah, this is probably the best, right?
But, uh... I don't know, maybe...
But I'm going for good afterwards, like just out of the way.
What?
There is that knife there, right?
Garbage can.
Good boy.
Knife.
BAU BAU.
BAU BAU!
Peta Pumpkin is biodegradable?
He is!
Not great, but okay for the moment.
Biodegradable?
Yeah.
Not biodegradable?
De-badable.
It's not great.
I agree.
It's sort of bad.
Biode-badable.
BAU BAU!
Well, Ruffians!
FUWAMOCO, we have something new!
Exciting!
Wow, we just released our very first ASMR voice pack, Ruffians!
BAU BAU!
Thank you!
Everyday with FUWAMOCO!
What did you think?
Yeah, it was my very first time in a serious attempted ASMR.
You bought it!
Yeah!
It made me super nervous!
BAU BAU!
Look the cute visual here.
So cute too!
You like the preview?
Yeah!
Right, there's a preview too.
Ruffians.
Wow.
You know, this is our first ASMR.
It wasn't just FUWAMOCO, you know, on our own.
We had two Patrasche!
She wrote Lifetime, Showtime, our original introduction song.
And then she's also known as the ASMR goddess.
I feel like we're the only ones that are calling her that.
She's definitely the ASMR goddess to me.
But she produced and oversaw everything of it!
And we even recorded it at her extra fancy ASMR studio too!
But you know, we've seen a bunch of very happy Ruffians!
Lots of great people!
Happy Ruffians!
Maybe happy is a simple word to describe it.
Very happy.
I don't know.
FUWAMOCO didn't vote in English and Japanese.
We hope you check it out.
And you know what the Ruffians are saying.
You can check out sample.
There's a sample on the hololive English YouTube with a very cute video.
Special video.
Or you can also go check it out on the official hololive shop and there's sample voices there as well.
I feel like...
The video is really long.
I was really surprised!
It's really long.
I feel like if it's on the official shop, it's a bit hidden.
Now it's on the YouTube.
Go take a look, Ruffians!
And please go check it out on the official hololive shop too!
We did our best!
Right, we did our best and we're really really excited to be able to do this very special project together with Patraone-san!
It was a long time in the works!
We're happy.
You know, finally it made it to the Ruffians part, you know.
Also, we had a very special 3D collab stream the other day with Patra Onee-san, too.
So please check out the archive here on our channel if you haven't yet.
We did a bunch of different things.
It's like a lot of different ASMR related games.
And things got very crazy.
Shoving it!
Right into my chest!
Patara oneesan is so bull.
She's like this, like this!
Here you go!
Right, she's so bull.
I learned a lot from her.
Yeah, she was...
Stepping on the Ruffians too, but we are doing our best to get off the bed!
I was getting ready!
Right?
And I just look over there like, what are you doing?
But we learn a lot from her, you know, not just ASMR, but a lot, a lot.
But you know, we also sung a very fun song together, played the unison dance,
Please check it out again!
We'll also be doing a special after party to talk about later this week, so please join us!
Yeah, and we'll kinda share maybe you know what went into it, our feelings and everything, you know?
Yeah!
So we hope that you'll join us, and please please go check out the voice pack on the hololive official shop too, okay, Ruffians?
BAU BAU!
Thank you!
It was really really special, so...
BAU BAU!
Wow!
There's more exciting news from hololive English!
Over Bay-sa-buy!
She just announced yesterday that she's going to be doing a very special 3D Live!
And it's happening this weekend on Saturday the 26th at 8pm PT!
So soon!
So soon right?
I was so surprised, but I'm really looking forward to it!
She said she's gonna be focused on performing performance.
Mama Shiori's gonna be lots of amazing dancing for sure!
It is a pain in the butt.
Right after all.
As expected of a pain in the butt.
And the title is Chuu-Nii-Bae.
At first I was like, oh that's cute, it's Chuchu-Bae!
It's like, oh that's very cute, Chuchu-Bae.
But maybe that'll be better suited for Valentine's Day.
Don't laugh at us, Ruffians!
We just read it!
I was thinking we could all be based off this title.
Go bow to FWMC.
It's not follow me, FUWAMOCO.
Although that kind of sounds cool too.
No.
No!
This is Bei-senpai's title.
It's me, Bei-senpai.
And we misread it.
Somehow.
BAU BAU!
I have a strong case of...
It's about me-byo.
No!
Make sure you don't miss it on KMOPT!
Big congratulations to Bei-senpai!
Yeah, and that again is on Saturday the 26th at 8pm PT.
Okay.
Let's make sure you know it.
Go check out everything that Bei-senpai's been working so hard for on KMOPT!
BAU BAU!
There's a lot of exciting things going on all around the globe right now!
Pop-up store happening right now in Taichung!
The hololive Chill Traveler based on hololive Super Expo 2025!
You know there's a lot of FUWAMOCO fans that love that aloha shirt!
This special pop-up store features over 250 limited edition products!
250!
I don't even know Ruffians.
Yeah, and of course you know there's acrylic stands, chibi items, foldable stuff, 4 holders, but there's also some very interesting things like helmets?
Motorcycle mudguards and helmets.
Yeah!
So if you want ice to protect your head,
We can.
You know that we don't have to ask Atama daijoubu?
Yeah!
Because we'll be protecting it!
Protecting it!
Okay!
Yeah, there's also visors too!
Yeah!
I really want to see what we're gonna... I'm so chill with my FUWAMOCO visor.
Yeah, and I think the... The motorcycle, my car, it says stop.
Stop!
Yeah, like the bike, the bike.
Yeah!
All right.
Basket.
Basket!
Yeah, there's also large life-size pillows!
Of course there are, Aloha Abyss!
I was surprised.
But there's also- Does the helmet do ASMR?
I don't think so.
Well, if you put a speaker inside and then... It's quite impossible!
You could always put your headphones and then put the helmet on and then... No noise!
Right, I don't know how ASMR while driving on the streets works, but...
FUWAMOCO Not only FUWAMOCO but other FUWAMOCO members too!
Collectible card machines!
Lots of things going on, so if you're in the area, please check it out!
Right now it's October 15th, and it'll be ending November 11th, so hopefully you can go over and try to get your paws on some of the very very interesting, unique merchandise that's available!
Not vegetable cards, collectible cards!
Vegetable cards wouldn't be too awful.
I don't know what the collectible cards are made of.
They could be from vegetables.
They could be.
They are probably from vegetables, but maybe not.
Maybe they're made out of plastic or acrylic.
Yeah.
I don't know what vegetables.
BAU BAU!
Moco-moco.
I don't know if you want to moco-moco those.
No, it's probably paper.
BAU BAU!
Don't try eating it.
Okay?
No.
Somewhere's coming to an end, but that's okay because just recently there was a brand new video series released on the hololive English channel called Secret Island Vacation with hololive English!
This is to get out more fans!
Wow, this video series, it's in the style of a visual novel!
And you know, depending on the next video you click on, the story kind of branches off.
It's a very cute project, you know?
And the script!
The script was actually written by Calli-senpai herself!
So Ruffians, if you haven't checked it out yet, please do!
You can see a bunch of us hololive English members
Swimsuits.
You know, having fun on a secret island.
It gets pretty silly too.
It's a bit silly.
But you know, we saw some Ruffians joking that FUWAMOCO are 1 million wishes granted within 2 days or less.
After reaching 1 million.
Huh?
Ruffians.
No.
It's totally separate, okay?
It's separate.
It's not true.
It's not misunderstanding!
No.
Yeah.
Okay, Ruffians!
I think for some people it's hard to understand.
When it's a joke.
But you know, this is just a fun visual novel style video series, right?
It's different.
And you know, well, FUWAMOCO!
We said that, you know, a visual novel game that that's what we would like to wish for with a million wishes.
You know, a FUWAMOCO visual novel game produced by FUWAMOCO!
This is our wish!
It's not coming out!
So, hyakuman ni?
Yeah.
So, kimatta tte waki janakute.
Yeah, I know it's, that's what we would like for our one million wish, but it doesn't mean that it's been granted or anything like that at all, Ruffians, so don't get confused, okay?
But yeah, you know what?
If it does get granted, it'll be very, very, very, very far off in the future, so...
Maybe look forward to happening someday, okay?
It's our wish.
You'll just have to stick around until it comes to fruition then, right?
BAU BAU!
Kanaetara ii ne?
Ii ne!
BAU BAU!
Ruffians!
More wishes!
Well, FUWAMOCO!
Just at the very beginning of August!
Yes!
Around our one year anniversary, we finally released our original song!
Boy to be BAU!
Yeah!
BAU BAU!
BAU BAU Ruffians!
I'm sure you've been listening to it lots and lots of nights!
Can you hear it right now?
Are you singing along right now?
Yeah!
BAU BAU!
Our original song was written by PandaBoY.
PandaBoY's done a lot of songs for hololive.
Idol songs too, you know.
Blue Clapper, a bunch of them, and Point to Be Bottles, one of them.
It's a very special song that I'm not sure you know well, so...
It just recently reached over 950,000 views on YouTube!
Over 950,000 views on YouTube!
Oh my god!
Thank you so much, my friend!
It's approaching the big one million!
One million!
We're forever going to have an original song!
One million views on YouTube!
It's a million!
Thank you so much, FU
It's just a little more!
And you can see, you know, the little Polly FUWAMOCO here dancing even more as well.
Heck yeah!
Oh BAU!
We're just so happy!
Thank you so much, Ruffians, for loving FUWAMOCO lots and lots!
We hope we can release even more music in the future too!
I know!
The next big goal that we're gonna aim for is a solo live.
And we kinda need original music for that.
Right!
So... We're gonna have fun!
BAU BAU!
Thank you!
FUWAMOCO, my favorite place in the world.
Akihabara MisDo.
It's gonna be closing.
Wait!
I can't hear you!
You know, we wanted to do something special.
And we wanted to buy a bunch of pon-de-rings from there and have a party!
A big party!
Yeah, and you know, we talked about before in the previous FUWAMOCO Morning about that we were able to buy 100 pon-de-rings at once.
And you know, so we wanted to do that again and ask Mane-chan for her to help us.
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
Have a howl of a day!
Yeah, but you know Mare-chan.
Mare-chan, she hasn't ordered a big amount of pon-de-rings before.
You know, that makes sense.
So she wasn't really very sure about how many we could order.
And especially, you know, there's gonna be closing soon, so we're busy.
Why?
But, ima Mari-chan was like, okay FUWAMOCO, I'll order as many as I can get my paws on!
And she was able to get 80 paws on!
We are so happy!
So we checked Twitter to see if Ruffians are going to Akibomi so we can still get pundies!
We were still having porno.
I was kind of worried, you know, if we buy a bunch of them.
I was a little worried.
I was worried that maybe all the Ruffians visiting the Akihabara MisDo, they wouldn't be able to get pornoings.
They still have pornoings, so I'm glad we didn't buy them all.
But you know, we're able to have a big porno party!
And you know...
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
Have a howl of a day!
They were all gone!
All EVE had disappeared!
Before we even finished up with the night!
We were so happy!
Everybody was so happy!
Right!
We didn't have any leftovers afterwards.
And we're so happy to be able to, you know, enjoy our last Akibameetsu department together!
And we got another very special receipt to treasure somehow.
How many do we eat?
Ruffians!
How many do you think we eat?
10 each.
2040!
17!
2.
We each had...
One!
Because you know, it was a big day for us so we were nervous.
We're not really in the pon-de-ring eating mode.
This song!
I have one and I was happy with my one.
Right, a very special one.
That's all I needed!
Ten each is basic!
But we are busy!
Ten each is a lot.
You know, if we couldn't be doing ASMR, we can't eat a bunch of pon-de-ring.
Same with dancing, you see!
Mine is already a lot!
I'm not hungry, I'm not hungry.
But it was a very special memory, so... A pon-de-ring ASMR soon?
No.
Like kinda when you put the piece of sashimi in front of the kitten and it's like...
No!
BAU BAU!
We hope that you can enjoy some pon-de-ring soon, Ruffians!
Let's check out who's our Doggie of the Day today!
Our Doggie of the Day is... De-den!
BAU BAU!
Here's my BAU BAU!
Today's Doggie of the Day is BAU BAU!
BAU BAU!
I don't think that's his name though.
Here is my BAU BAU.
Look at how relaxed this doggy is.
How relaxed BAU BAU is.
BAU BAU's tummy is just like... BAU BAU.
Look at those paws.
Those cute little cross paws.
Very sweet.
We have perfect ears too.
Very triangle.
They look very similar to certain someone's, huh?
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
Maybe after 10 fun days.
Maybe!
BAU BAU!
FUWAMOCO-chan!
How does BAU BAU BAU BAU?
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
We should all aspire to be like BAU BAU here.
Especially with the cold season coming up.
BAU BAU!
So much BAU BAU!
BAU BAU BAU BAU!
Wow!
Let's take a look, Ruffians!
You've been continuing your walks, right?
Yeah!
Let's see where you went on today!
I went on a walk!
We have... De-den!
You were able to stop by and have some fun over at Round1!
And look, you got our special collab drinks and coasters!
Oh my gosh, and the Ruffian plushies are there with you too!
BAU BAU!
In case you don't know, Ruffians, right now, Round1, we have a special collab!
There's a special hololive event happening at Round1 Entertainment Center locations all across Japan and the US right now.
So you can go check it out too!
But I'm so glad this Ruffian looks like they had a super fun time.
Maybe they did some karaoke or bowling.
Or some of the UFO Catching game.
But there'll be even more fun stuff released and happening soon at Wawon, so we hope that you can go soon, Ruffians!
Yeah, please check it out!
BAU BAU!
I'm so happy to see lots of Ruffians going!
Right, everyone's having fun!
BAU BAU!
Let's take a look at our Question of the Day.
We have De-den!
Hi FUWAMOCO!
I've been participating in a lot of collaborations with other hololive members lately.
I was wondering if you would be interested in organizing some kind of project yourself someday.
It's great to see so many different kinds of collaborations.
We've been having lots of fun.
We've been really happy to be getting lots of different invitations to collabs recently.
But FUWAMOCO, you know, we've been thinking that it would be nice one day to organize our own big collab.
But recently,
We get a bit nervous when we are organizing things, you know.
Not only is it kind of hard for us to figure out the best game, the right game to play.
We get really nervous, you know, if our collab partners are having a lot of fun and the viewers are all having fun.
Sometimes we aren't really able to relax and have fun ourselves.
So, you know for now I think we kind of prefer to be able to focus on our own projects and have fun together with everyone else in other ways.
Yeah, get a bit more experience right first.
Yeah, maybe that's a little bit better.
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
We need to go to the onsen, eat some yaki mochi, relax.
That sounds goooood.
Well thank you so much Ruffians for all of your submissions!
Please don't forget that FUWAMOCO is something that we make together.
FUWAMOCO Morning.
Ah.
FUWAMOCO is us.
It's something that we make together with you, so we're always looking for your Doggie of the Day.
Send us your doggy!
Your Pero Sighting so we can all stay informed.
And be disciplined a bit.
That we can get some of your questions, you know?
And also see the walks that you've been going on, especially with all the leaves changing colors and everything.
It'll be nice.
Please let us know with the hashtag.
Hashtag FWMCMORNING!
BAU BAU!
We have another scene coming up rather soon.
Let's take a look.
Alright next scene we have De-den!
It's gonna be having our first ASMR afterparty!
We wanted to talk all about it, what it was like, our feelings.
I hope she knows what it was like together.
She wanna know what you thought too.
Yeah, we wanna talk all about it.
We wanna be able to have a chat together with you and have a bit of an afterparty to do that.
Yeah, what went on?
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
BAU BAU!
Cuz I'm just expecting an interview with a vampire.
Nerissa wanted to watch it and you know knowing Nerissa it's probably like a vampire that Nerissa would like.
So I don't think it's gonna be a scary vampire.
So he'll have the white hair like the guy from Baldur's Gate?
Yeah!
I don't know if he's a vampire though.
Is he just a guy like a bad guy?
I don't know.
Probably somebody like that will be interviewing him.
Then who's the Baldur's Gate guy?
Remingo.
Eldin.
Asterion!
Close to Eldin!
That was close!
He doesn't have any rings.
No!
It's Thursday!
It's a day shrouded in mystery!
Very early in the morning!
On question question question mark channel we have question question question mark.
Don't know much about it except that it's gonna be happening at 5am PT or 6am!
8am!
ET!
So it might be a little bit early but well I'm sure it'll probably be very silly!
Hi.
Don't worry.
Question, question, question mark.
Bye bye!
BAU BAU!
I think it was just recently announced, but there's gonna be some hololive EM racing also happening!
I'm a little bit nervous, but there's also gonna be some exciting things going on, not just racing maybe!
I said of course that I know we should practice, but I heard that it's very very difficult.
And that, rather than having a controller, you should have an actual wheel.
I'm wondering if we order a wheel, will it arrive in time?
It's really important!
Let's order a wheel, Moco-chan!
I wanna see it too!
Okay, you have one paw on the wheel, I'll have one paw on the wheel.
Extreme realism?
Yeah!
Are you sure you wanna see us racing with extreme realism?
Let's do our best, Moco-chan.
BAU BAU!
I'm fighting!
We have another FUWAMOCO Morning, but in the evening it's about to get a bunch of spookiness, because we're playing Five Nights at Freddy's 2.
I know I played at the pool, but it's because I didn't know what to play.
We almost beat the first one!
Apparently we're pretty good at it.
Maybe we'll be pretty good at the second one.
We're gonna need your help!
And then Saturday we're gonna be doing a watch-along with Mikocchi-senpai's first solo live!
I'm so excited, Mikocchi-senpai!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
Recommended a long time ago.
We didn't forget because Fubuki-senpai recommended it.
Massage.
Not a massage.
I wish it was a massage.
It's a massage.
Although if it's by ghosts, I don't want it.
Yeah, but Fubuki-senpai said FUWAMOCO you should play it, so we're gonna play it!
Please hold our paws, Moco-chan.
We're gonna need lots of paw holding, okay?
Advent Sunday!
We're gonna be having a nice, calm, relaxing time.
No spooky!
And just chatting together with you and doing some super chat reading as well.
And that's all we coming up here!
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much Ruffians for joining us today for FUWAMOCO Morning!
Before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Ruffians today!
Wowow!
BAU BAU!
Enjoy security!
Quacks!
BAU BAU!
Magic Magician!
Porkchop!
BAU BAU!
Kahoon!
Gokuma!
BAU BAU!
Jousting!
And to every other Ruffian out there, we hope you have a howl of a day!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita!